hey everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for march 25th
2021 and i have a feeling that a whole
bunch of you might have
two screens open right now because the
man pretending to be president joe biden
is giving his first
press conference in over two months of
being president but i know that you're
good loyal viewers of the reuben report
so you're watching me
you're watching the president and side
by side it's now up to you to decide who
makes more sense
uh there's a lot of weirdness coming out
of this press conference it just started
about 15 minutes ago
if you're not watching it or even if you
have watched it or you're in the midst
of watching it
we're gonna we're just gonna throw you
one clip right now and you tell me
if joe biden is okay here we go
so the best way to get something done if
you
if it holds near and dear to you that
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're going to get a lot done and if
we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh sing me miss kim
what am i supposed to add to that i am
not showing that clip
to be a dick like did i vote for the guy
no
do i think that the democrats have gone
completely insane yes
would i prefer that the president of the
united states be cognitively okay
be would i prefer that we were all
confident
that this man was a sensible steward of
our country
of course this is actually depressing
and as many times as i talk about it i
will i don't want to do it every time
but i will
occasionally throw in the caveat that
i'm not trying to be glib
about cognitive issues or dementia or
alzheimer's or any of those things
one of my grandmas had it had dementia
and i spent a lot of time going to
geriatric hospitals with her and all the
specialists and all of that stuff
and around the repetition and sometimes
the anger and forgetting what
you're saying and all of those things
that man should not be president of the
united states i don't think i'm
saying anything that's particularly
controversial if you care about america
this is not a partisan issue
something is seriously wrong there
let's also keep in mind he's getting
pre-packaged questions all from friendly
reporters that he obviously knows
what the questions are he has tons of
notes in front of him he can't do this
he cannot do this job and if you think
he's in charge of this operation i got a
bridge to say i mean it's very
it's very very confusing people like
something ain't
right and we're just not supposed to see
it so you tell me
tonight don't take my word for it tell
me tonight if cnn will cover that and
whatever other gaps
happen you should tell me if they're
going to do it i'm not going to watch
cnn i mean somebody will probably send
me the clips
but i'm not going to do it you tell me
if the new york times covers it you tell
me if the washington post covers it
or if they don't want you to see a
certain something
and then they can package whatever they
like out of him whatever sensible stuff
he can put together that fits their
narrative
if they can put that as the headline or
that is the lead story
and then you just kind of don't see the
other stuff thus leaving us in a
constant reality war where some people
see the truth
and some people see nonsense what are we
going to do about this i don't know what
the answer is i don't know what the
answer is
however while joe biden takes
pre-packaged questions that he was
prepped on
and has notes for i'm doing a live q a
today we got about 100 questions
at the reubenreport.locals.com community
my producer michael selected them
they're right in front of me here
i don't prepare in advance we're just
going to figure it out but before we get
to that guys i want to talk to you about
ancestry.com
did your great-grandmother work hard to
raise her children and keep her family
together
did your family preserve persevere
through natural disasters to rebuild and
start anew
was there a health care worker in your
family's past who cared for another
generation facing a pandemic our
ancestors were ordinary people who lived
through extraordinary situations
something we can all understand today
challenging times are nothing new
neither are resilient people learning
about the struggles and adversity your
family went through can bring you closer
to your own family today
as you share stories from new bonds
ancestry helps you search billions of
records to learn more about the
ancestors who came through remarkable
challenges
so you could be here today you can find
details about their lives see what they
did to earn a living in a census record
or see their actual signature
on a military record as they signed up
to fight for the country
learning their stories helps you find a
connection to what they went through and
how they stood strong through hardships
and struggles
when you get closer to your ancestors by
learning their stories you have a new
way
to get closer to your family there's
strength in every family story and you
can learn more
about your family at ancestry.com reuben
to start your free trial that's
ancestry.com reuben
and now back to me okay i want to show
you two quick videos about masks
from yesterday before we get to the q a
uh first off
first up ted cruz was doing a little
impromptu
press conference yesterday and a
reporter confronted him
because he wasn't wearing a mask
uh yeah when i'm talking to the tv
camera i'm not going to wear a mask and
all of us have been immunized
so you're welcome to
step away if you like
the whole point of a vaccine cdc
guidance
is what we're following yeah good job
ted
i generally like ted you guys have
probably seen the video of me playing
nintendo with him at my house
he's a good guy i think he makes sense i
think he cares about the country cares
about the constitution
cares about personal liberty cares about
freedom we've all been immunized
this is absolute theater that a reporter
would ask him to do it
and that is the type of attitude that
are good
public leaders and there ain't many of
them need to take with the media like
that's just
absolute theater that's that guy trying
to control cruz cruz wouldn't have it
and that's sort of a beautiful thing
then i saw this one
uh this is from cbs mexico's newest
trend related to masks
[Music]
lord lord up in the sky give me the
strength
give me the strength uh what you're
seeing there are people wearing masks
over their nose now they still wear the
face mask they take that off
so that they can eat using their mouth
their bokeh
but they keep the nose mask on to make
sure that germs aren't spreading out of
the nose
i guarantee you there's no science
behind this and this is just complete
lunacy
like pretty much everything or
as they say in mexico
okay people let's get to a q a and again
the biden thing's still going on
we might live stream a little later if
we just get like a whole bunch more
crazy clips and i'll i'll analyze them
for you but
we shall see in any event we're going to
do about 10 questions right now here we
go
clickaholic says is the u.s to blame for
central americans coming here
or is it their governments ah that's a
complex one up top well
first you know i was just watching some
of the biden thing and one of the
questions by a pbs
journalist who's really just a
democratic activist was in effect what
you know what are you doing about the
border what's going on here
people like you so much you were thought
of as so nice and biden was basically
like
you know well the reason they're coming
is because i'm nice you know i'm a lot
nicer than that other guy and that's why
they're coming and
okay yeah i'm nice that's great now look
we are a nation of immigrants
what does it say on the statue of
liberty something about the huddled
masses you come here the tired the poor
the whole thing and virtually everyone
makes a better life for themselves and
then the generation after them is better
and all that good stuff you guys know
all about that stuff i don't have to
sell you on any of that
however as i said the other day we got
some problems now
we got major major problems we got a
president with dementia that's on the
list
on top of the economy and whatever's
left with covid and lockdowns and a
horrific mainstream media
and all those those things so we got
some stuff we got to work on here
and now we have all these immigrants
rushing the border and they're basically
sort of being told you can stay or you
kind of have to go back or we're going
to put you in these cages or maybe we're
going to fly you up north
so when you say who's to blame whether
it's sort of us or it's the central
american countries
the leadership in these countries and
the media i think it's everybody we
the united states have given very very
mixed messages we've played a couple
clips
about this over the last few weeks where
biden administration officials
in effect have been saying oh you can
come but not right now we've got to work
things out
but that sort of is winking to the
people like come because you know we're
not just going to send you back
right we'll we'll get you in some
facility and then we'll figure out
something
and then you have the democrats trying
to push all this legislation where we're
going to give all these people benefits
and
and all sorts of crazy stuff and i also
thought i thought we had a pandemic yet
we're keeping people in cages
in these little you saw these metallic
blankets i mean
the whole thing is very bizarre so i
would say it's partly our fault in that
we it's very obvious the democrats want
more people here right they want more
people here for the sort of finishing
blow
on democracy right like they want more
people here for more voters that's why
they want dc statehood
and the rest of it because they just
want to clinch the game that they've
been playing for a while and politics is
a messy game that's not to say the
republicans are so great because they're
not
but the democrats obviously want more
people here knowing oh we can just give
them a lot of handouts they'll become
reliant on us they'll vote for us
we become a one-party country and adios
democracy and adios
freedom and adios the united states of
america so i do blame our administration
in that regard i have no doubt and i
don't know that i have enough
information and i assure you nobody
on cnn that's you know pretending to be
a news anchor does
about what specifically you know the
leaders in these central american
countries or the or the political
pundits
or the media class whatever it is what
they're saying to them
to to you know get these people to be
pushed over but we know that there's a
lot of money in trafficking people and
the rest of it so i think everyone's
probably to blame
and if you want like if i was an elected
official
god forbid my policy would be simple
right now about the border well first
off in general about the borders every
country has a right to defend its
borders as it sees fit
that's the point of having a country
that's the point of having sovereign
nations
you've got a geographic area you can
defend it and what goes on in your area
is up to you
and you probably shouldn't attack the
other people but if they're coming for
you you're allowed to attack them you
know we can get into all the
the ins and outs of all of that but my
policy would be sorry we're shutting
everything down for a little while we're
in the middle of this
uh they're telling us the worst pandemic
in a hundred years and all of this stuff
it's like we got some stuff to figure
out we'll
we'll get back to you we'll get back to
you because we got to take care of our
house first
isaiah says as the left continues to try
and dismantle
our constitution and almost entirely get
rid of our second amendment rights will
states be able to push back on federal
orders
this is a huge huge question i'm glad
you asked this
because one of the clips that i played a
couple times during
the democratic debates was when
kamala harris before she dropped out
polling at zero percent
was talking about executive actions on
guns
right and that was the question will you
do an executive action on guns now
from everything i understand about the
constitution and i'm not a
constitutional scholar but i've talked
to a lot of constitutional scholars and
i have a little understanding
of the separation of powers the federal
government
can't pass a law that would infringe on
one of our god-given rights in the bill
of rights right the second amendment the
right to bear arms so you can't do
an executive action on guns now that's
not really the way we're governed
because everyone does everything by
executive actions and
unfortunately the paper that is the
constitution is being trampled on all
the time
in any event there was a question asked
of joe biden first
about would you do an executive action
on guns
and we'll we'll find the clip and we'll
play it again next week because it's a
really profound moment michael make sure
we grab that
um joe biden in essence says well you'd
have to do it constitutionally you can't
just do that it would have to be
constitutional
and then the camera pans over to kamala
harris and with her evil cackle f
she goes joe joe can't we just say yes
we can
[Laughter]
joe a little rush to the head there
that tells you the fundamental
difference between these people joe
biden who obviously is not cognitively
right i believe
that he at his heart and at his best
wanted to do things the right way
probably 20 years ago doesn't mean i
agree with all the decisions but wanted
to
do something that was constitutional and
within the guidelines of the system
kamala harris does not care and that's
that's also the real danger that's
happening right now because when they
get rid of biden which they will get rid
of biden obviously
she's going to step in and would she
would she be more than happy to sign an
executive action on guns well she
already said
that she would and again she was polling
at zero percent
in her own party when she stepped down
and then they picked her
why would they pick someone polling at
zero percent
meditate on that i will ej says how
young should we start talking to kids
about these big topics
blm inc critical race theory
intersectionality politics stuff because
if we don't they'll hear it from school
or youtube where the cartoon network
well yeah good god i'm glad you
mentioned the cartoon network because we
had that ridiculous
cartoon that we played a couple weeks
ago that promo they did all with like
the worst sort of social justice
nonsense
and that your race actually matters more
and it's like your point is a good one
because as a parent what do you do
you put kids in front of the tv
sometimes you put kids in front of ipads
you don't know what
they're seeing you know we don't have
kids yet we're working on it but once we
have kids you know i'm gonna have a
couple years
you know before they're say four or five
when they can start ingesting
information in that regard
that so i have i have a window to play
with right now where i can talk about
this i suppose at an ideal level and not
like the granular oh i've got kids what
am i doing level uh but i do have
nieces and nephews and i've discussed
this with my brother and my sister and
my
and their husbands and wives and it's
like it's really tough
like i don't think you should be sitting
five-year-olds down and talking to them
about all of these things kids don't see
color kids kids are good
you know if you teach them the right
things about being a good person and all
of those things like that will
that will transcend some of this stuff
and then your point though
is valid because it's like well all
right if you don't warn them about some
of these bad ideas
they're going to start hearing them and
this goes to what i've been saying about
public schools it's like how can you
send your kid
to a public school at this point if you
have the means not to do so
and obviously not everyone does but this
is also sadly why democrats don't want
school choice because they want
these indoctrination centers to be run
why does bernie sanders want everyone to
get free college well what a great place
to brainwash everybody it's not because
he wants
everyone to learn about capitalism right
he doesn't want everyone to start
reading thomas soul
while in college he wants them to be
brainwashed into being the next
generation of socialists
um so this is a huge issue and i think
the best that any of us can do
whether it's your kids or your siblings
or your parents or
whatever just keep breaking it down into
that local level and and you got to
figure it out for your kid but i
i would imagine it would be very scary
to have say a fifth grader right now
uh who one day is coming home and is
suddenly extremely confused about their
gender identity or so
or suddenly thinks that you're a racist
or a series of other things not because
any of it's true
but just because it's endlessly
discussed in school as opposed to
teaching them say
math or science or economics or
history well they teach them history but
you know it's not the right history
anymore so
it's a huge problem it's a great
question i'd love to actually if any of
you are our parents i'd love to uh
hear some of your thoughts on that uh so
comment in the post
from this video on
reubenreport.locals.com
uh oh and by the way we are doing a
panel tomorrow all about education so i
will bring this up thanks for the heads
up over there
uh so we have three people all experts
in education
all related to all of this so that will
be tomorrow live at 11 a.m pacific
anya asks what do you think needs to
happen so people wake up from kovid
mania fear
and unreasonable thinking man
i don't know i don't know uh i'm not
gonna sit here and say that i had a few
people over for dinner last night again
that would be
highly illegal and not something that
someone like me would do and that video
that i posted on twitter of all the uh
glasses
filled with whiskey that was clearly
that was done on photoshop i didn't
really
do that with other people i mean come on
what do you think i am a murderer or
something
um i don't know how do you break people
out of fear
what has affected us more really as a
nation as a
as a populist in the world was it
coveted or was it the lockdowns
the destruction of jobs the the
depression the alcoholism all those
things was it the disease itself
or was it what we then allowed them to
do to us
in the name of protecting us from said
disease you tell me which
which one affected you more that's not
to diminish you know about 500 000
people
died in the united states a huge huge
percentage of them
were elderly people with at least one
other comorbidity
usually obesity or diabetes and often a
whole bunch of other things
that doesn't that doesn't take away that
doesn't diminish their deaths it's still
sad no matter what we also had the
lowest amount of flu deaths
uh i think since recording something
like that last year so that's
that's very bizarre but the fear is what
i always feared
they say there's nothing to fear but
fear itself but i say the fear is what i
always feared because
it was the idea that once we started
this thing two weeks to flatten the curb
and we knew it wasn't going to be two
weeks but we all played along
and then it was okay now we're just
going to shut down till april and then
april rolled around and i remember when
newsom said now we're going to shut down
until august and i was saying there of
course they're going to continue it
again in august
and now guys we're at the end of march
in the following year
and i still see here in l.a people
almost
everyone actually walking around in
masks and
you know i talk about all the time you
walk your dog downstream they pull the
dogs away from each other and the dogs
are fearful
it's like how do you break out of that
and and the training
that we have done to young people so
that oh authorities said something you
better follow it no matter what no
whoa you asking questions we're going to
delete your youtube channel
like there is there is such a cascade
of problems that i don't think we can
fully acknowledge right now because one
thing we do and social media has done
this to us
we live in the in the moment to moment
right now and we don't think about
what's coming or what was
and we got to start thinking about it
better and remove ourselves from some of
that stuff so i
i don't know uh but i can tell you this
this is also where the federalist system
kind of works because when i've been in
florida most
of the people that i saw were way less
fearful and what the hell am i doing
here good question
it wasn't asked specifically but thank
you for bringing it up for
myself and my internal thought process
ginger says i love trump's actions and
policies do you think it's possible he
contributed
to cancel culture with name calling yes
to some degree of course
right like trump trump was the blunt
instrument for a time when a lot of evil
was spreading
trump was not a perfect man i have no
doubt trump has done
immoral things trump probably womanized
lied probably didn't do all the most
honest things related to business i
think in essence he was just
a new york city real estate guy that's a
freaking tough business
that is a tough business going making
all your money in the 70s 80s 90s
in new york business like you're gonna
have to go through a lot of crap
owning casinos in vegas in atlantic city
like
well he also owned casinos in vegas but
you know most of the stuff was in
atlantic city like
that sort of world and the relationship
to
big business and the mafia and all of
that stuff it's just it's all stuff that
was there and he kept fighting it and
fighting and fighting it what i always
say is
if you watch those videos which you can
still get on youtube at least for now of
trump in the 80s
on phil donahue on oprah asking him if
he's going to run for president
in essence he was saying the same exact
things he's less orange his affect is a
little softer
but over time as he kind of went against
the machine
he fought back using every tool he had
right he brought
women that had accused bill clinton of
rape
to the debates with hillary clinton he
called people names he was petty at
times all of those things
did i love all of that stuff of course
not actually the first time around
that's very much why i was against him
but i came to realize only a very
imperfect
creature who would do what it was
necessary to do to fight
the much bigger monster that is the
democratic party plus the media
that he was a sort of needed he was a
needed beast
in a way but did he contribute to cancer
culture because
because it made it very easy for
everything to get ramped up yes
one of the interesting things is when
i've talked to my very wise
liberal friends the last remaining few
liberals who
in essence i think have gotten
everything wrong but if the few that
will still talk to me
they many of them were saying oh after
after trump
lost the election many of them were
saying well don't worry because now that
biden's in charge even though we don't
think biden's great just the idea
that trump is gone it will lower the
temperature the temperature will now be
lowered well
does anyone honestly think the
temperature has been lowered are people
getting less cancelled now does the
tenor seem better
uh we were told we have to heal h-e-a-l
when mostly they mean h-e-e-l
uh this is this is a problem that we
gotta deal with so i think he probably
contributed to it for sure
uh but i wouldn't say he was the main
factor i would just say he was a symptom
within that
uh seti says how big of a paycheck would
it take
for you to play the lead role in a
bernie sanders biopic
i'm bernie sanders and i think you're a
right-wing racist and i want your money
i'm gonna give it to him and i'm bernie
sanders and i'm
jackie mason um
i guess if somebody was willing to pay
for me to do that
i might be willing to do it um but
probably larry david
should be doing it right that would be
the best
version of it pamela says locals is a
great concept if we're all focused on
improving ourselves and helping our
local community
then there really wouldn't be a need for
heavy national government or
overreaching world power
testify sister how can we do a better
job of spreading local vibes in a more
contagious way
love this question this is not going to
be the most fun answer but i think
really try to meet some of your
neighbors
they may not be that friendly i live in
la it's not the friendliest group people
but
some of the neighbors are nice and you
know when we moved here
the neighbors next door actually brought
us a little gift basket a little
champagne in there a little chocolate
some dog food for clyde
you know some dog treats um try to
realize that even though i've only seen
them like a handful of times since then
it's like oh they welcomed us to the
neighborhood we owe you know we say hi
all the time you know it's a weird time
because of the pandemic obviously
but like i don't care what their
politics are i genuinely don't care i
suspect they're probably not that close
to my politics
um but me making friends or at least
acquaintances or saying hello to people
that's why i always bring up the hello
thing
uh when you're walking the streets
because it's so important to realize
that these are
other people they're actual
living breathing human beings with the
same fears that you have the same
uh drive and passions that you have all
of our levers are pulled and pushed a
little bit differently
but we're all human beings here and i
think the best thing you do is get
involved in your local community know
who you
your local representative is you know
it's like we want the government the
federal government to do everything and
it's like well
my local government they're not doing a
great job with homelessness here right i
keep telling you about under the highway
here that these homeless guys are
building like a massive complex
at this point they're not doing that
good of a job
you know with say lowering taxes so that
we could maybe have more businesses come
back
that would be nice get involved at that
level because the nobody's coming to
save you i mean that's the thing so
knowing your neighbors i think is
important
important and then knowing who your
representatives are
and you know i'll try one other thing
with you too and i'm writing about this
in my next book
is that if you take care of your
property really take care of your
property like make sure your lawn is
mowed make sure
um you know the cobwebs aren't all over
your house doesn't it doesn't matter if
you have a
great house or a little shack or
whatever like actually bring your
garbage cans in when it's not
when it's not garbage pick-up day if you
do little things so that when someone
walks by
your home they go oh there's someone who
cares a little bit cares a little bit
about themselves cares a little bit
about the community
they might start doing it they might
start doing it i actually
am writing about this in my next book
and i'll have more on that in the next
couple weeks
but in the in the previous place that we
lived um when we moved there a lot of
people just left their garbage cans out
on the street all day long so we started
doing it and after a year of living
there i realized that when i went to
other neighborhoods like nicer
neighborhoods because we didn't live in
the nicest neighborhood it was fine but
it wasn't
it wasn't spectacular i realized well
wait a minute other people put all their
trash cans away and i live
in an area a couple square blocks where
everyone leaves their garbage cans out
like
that tells you a little something and
all it takes is one guy to do it and
then you might go
hey you know i'm gonna do that too and
suddenly enough people do it and then
your neighborhood looks a lot nicer
like i know that may sound like little
minutiae or maybe not even that
important but i are
i do think that there are little ways to
contribute to your community
and you don't even have to say hello to
anyone to do that sort of thing
jeff says when do you think disney plus
will remove the star wars prequel
trilogy because of the racist portrayal
of jar jar binks yes well look
you want to play by their rules disney i
mean
misa jamaican what happened um
like right like i guess he was a bad
jamaican
parody right and people have made a
point of this that the the separatist
leaders you know newt ginray and and the
other guy whatever his name was
that they were bad asian stereotypes i
don't know if it was just lazy writing
by george lucas and by the way guys you
know my feelings about the prequels i
think they get better and better over
time and they're going to be
looked at very very differently than the
way most people look at them now and the
struggle between
between power and starting a war so that
you can keep obtaining power and the
story of palpatine is phenomenal and the
last three sucked okay blah blah blah
but lisa got a big problem because misa
a racist portrayal of a jamaican what
are we gonna do
yeah so go ahead disney like you want to
do it i've got the dvd copy because i
know they're taking all the digital
stuff away from us at some point anyway
uh sean roo says what happened to
clyde's nancy pelosi chew toy
so somebody sent us a bunch of chew toys
for clyde and
and uh you know people send us all sorts
of stuff and if you've ever sent
anything to us like thank you like
we have we have a lot of stuff actually
we're going to do some giveaways because
people send us a lot of stuff we keep as
much as we can but like
i would need another house at this point
so we'll do some giveaways of of books
and extra
trinkets and and odd things and people
send me artwork and we do keep again as
much as we can but
we're gonna do some giveaways uh via the
locals community but anyway he
destroyed that thing i mean he
dismantled
nancy pelosi i want to go on the record
that i do not endorse
political violence i am completely
against violence
at all times against anyone we should
not be doing that
uh but clyde man he was mounting that
thing
he was just ripping her apart shredded
her we had just
the nancy pelosi with no stuffing which
is probably what nancy pelosi would look
like without the botox
and we had that for a while
we had that for a while and uh then we
we got rid of that thing so he's uh he's
working on a big snake right now as we
got we got a big snake right now which
is actually come to think of it sort of
like nancy pelosi
yeah all right guys part two of my
interview with lawrence fox british
actor who actually is becoming
a politician started his own political
party to fight back on so much of the
stuff that i talk about here all the
time
started the reclaimed party he's running
for mayor of london
uh it's up right now and of course the
full episode is up at
reubenreport.locals.com
absolutely free and we are doing a
panel on education tomorrow we're gonna
have corey d'angelis from reason
magazine
jill simonian from prageru
and sam sorbo who's kevin sorbo's wife
and she's a homeschool advocate i
actually met her a couple
a couple weeks back in florida great
lady so i'm looking forward to chatting
with all of them
i thank you guys for watching and again
if you had the double screens up i hope
i
i just hoped that i did a little bit
better than joe biden i didn't have to
do much today right because he's doing a
q a in effect i'm doing a q a
and all i had to do was have half the
ability to say
anything somewhat sensible i think i
pretty much did that so if we were
grading me today
you know i thought yesterday's show for
example was an a i was on point i felt
good about it we were sharp and ready to
roll today it would just be a pass fail
right because it doesn't matter
what i really did here i just had to do
a little bit better than old joe
anyway we're going to look at some of
the clips as they keep rolling
throughout the day and we may do a bonus
live stream a little bit later i'm on
i'm on a whole bunch of shows today i
think i'm on oan later
i was on newsmax this morning i'm on
another podcast a little later today so
it's going to be a busy one
uh oh and last thing as i said we got
some major locals announcements
which i believe we can drop secretly
at reubenreport.locals.com tomorrow and
then we will announce publicly on monday
anyway uh good talk everybody i enjoyed
this hope you did too have a great day
and i'll see you tomorrow